foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining me this afternoon
or this evening depending on where
you're joining from
um today I have the pleasure of talking
to you about congenital cytomegalovirus
or CMV and I'm going to make the kit the
case for newborn screening
um a little bit about myself before we
dig in so I am president-elect of the
national CMV Foundation
um and we do a lot of advocacy around
CMV screening and awareness I'm also an
assistant professor of developmental and
behavioral pediatrics at the University
of Michigan and I run our congenital CMV
developmental follow-up Clinic there
which is a ton of fun
um so I'm excited to get to talk to you
about one of my favorite topics today
so
um quick disclosure so I did say I'm as
I am affiliated with the national CMV
Foundation I am a consultant for
dinosaur and molecular and Medscape I
have research funding from the Gerber
foundation and the American Heart
Association this talk was sponsored
um by diasaurine molecular although they
didn't have any contributions in terms
of the content or you know telling me
what to say
so briefly I wanted to talk about the
learning objectives for today just to
give you an overview of where we're
going so I'm going to summarize the
prevalence talk about disease
manifestation treatment and management
of congenital CMV I want to talk about
current clinical guidelines and
laboratory methods used to diagnose
congenital CMV infections and then
briefly we'll touch on some new
screening approaches as well as some
legislative updates here in the U.S
so now I've got a pretty broad audience
here so I just wanted to take a step
back and make sure we're all on the same
here we go there my slide caught up
so I want to take a step back and make
sure we're all on the same page um in
terms of what we're talking about here
so um cytomegalovirus or CMV it's a
common DNA virus
um again this is like the Delta Airlines
you know view from 30 000 feet
um it infects people of all ages
um and you know by around 40 about 60
percent of U.S adults will have been
exposed infected at some time and in
developing countries possibly up to 90
percent depending on the study so it is
a ubiquitous virus it is everywhere
so a bit more CMV is found in all
tissues
um it is latent and becomes latent in
lymphocytes and monocytes and throughout
the life course of the host uh CMV is
intermittently reactivated
there are primary CMV infections where
someone is infected with CMV for the
very first time and then non-primary
infections which include you know
reactivation also if someone was to get
another strain of the virus which we all
know happens all the time and I feel
like the general public has had a crash
course in this with covid recently
unfortunately
uh important to know about CMV is that
most healthy individuals have no
symptoms or very very mild symptoms like
some people might have
um some fatigue or some lymph nodes but
the majority of people are asymptomatic
and it's really kind of um an infection
that you probably would never know you
had unless you were immunosuppressed or
kind of in these um you know these
specific groups
now CMV before we dive into congenital
CMV which is when um a infant or fetus I
should say is infected via the placenta
um in utero but other diseases
associated with CMV include
mononucleosis they can go hand in hand
we see CMV pneumonia as well as cardiac
infections CNS infections GI infections
retinitis hepatitis and you know I think
um you hear a lot about CMV when talking
about AIDS or immunosuppression because
it really is a virus that can be really
ugly in those populations organ
transplant as well who are
immunosuppressed
so CMV is transmitted through bodily
fluids you know I've got a drooly baby
here I'm a pediatrician so I see a lot
of drooly babies in clinic and saliva
especially of young children seems to be
a way that it is uh transmitted um quite
frequently I've got um a little baby
sleeping here beside me too so um
apologies if you hear any noises
um just wanted to kind of give you a
heads up in advance
um and so um CMV can be transmitted in
almost any bodily fluid so
um tears urine sexual fluids so you know
vaginal secretions semen
um breast milk is a big one and then of
course like in the blood like through
the placenta which is how we get
congenital CMV
and as a reminder so horizontal
transmission
um is when uh the virus in this case CMV
is transmitted from one person outside
the uterus a one born person to another
born person but vertical transmission is
via the placenta to the fetus and that's
really where we see a lot of issues and
that is congenital CMV
so in a nutshell as I said the fetus is
infected in utero so what so this is the
leading non-genetic cause of neonatal
and childhood hearing loss there's also
some risk of neurodevelopmental delays
and a little bit later I'm going to go
through kind of in Broad strokes and
neuropathogenesis of CMV congenital CMV
which will really help tie together kind
of why there are these possible sequelae
here's a statistic that blows my mind
roughly 30 000 U.S infants are born with
congenital CMV each year so another way
to look at that is that's one in 200 U.S
infants which is so high and I think um
you know people have called it the um
the
most common virus that no one knows
about or no one's talking about and
again in the general public there really
just has not been this public health
discourse about CMV even though it's
been around forever and we've known
about it forever
um
but
um you know there I have a lot of
theories but
um it is out there and it is really
common
so to really Hammer this point home
congenital CMV is more common than all
the disorders so the endocrine and
metabolic disorders screened for on the
recommended uniform screening panel
which is um the national panel that is
recommended that state screen for for
newborn screening so all those
conditions combined are common than
trisomy 21 or down syndrome pediatric
HIV fetal alcohol syndrome and these
other you know congenital listeria and
toxoplasmosis you know when we're
pregnant we hear all about don't eat
soft cheeses don't eat lunch meat you
know don't scoop the kitty litter but um
which is important I'm not minimizing
that but we don't typically hear a lot
about CMV prevention which is a problem
and I'm happy happy to say that that
seems to be changing
this figure here I'll just walk you
through it really quickly so it's
awareness versus incidence of congenital
conditions in the U.S so that top x-axis
is the number of children disabled by
the condition each year and those are
the orange circles or dots there
um the bars represent the percentage of
women who have even heard of that
condition
so you can see going down
um second to last there you see Down
syndrome Trisomy 21. so roughly 90 I'm
going to say of women that's the blue
bar have heard of down syndrome and
roughly five well just under six
thousand um children each year are
disabled born with um Trisomy 21. so you
know on this scale those are about equal
awareness and incidents
um but then going up to that very top
bar for congenital CMV excuse me you can
see that only about nine percent of
women have heard of congenital CMV yet
that dot of how many the incidence is
way out there you know similar to
trisomy 21 at around 6 000. and so the
6000 is the number of babies that are
thought to be disabled long-term by the
condition
um yet as you may recall I mentioned
earlier around 30 000 babies are born
with congenital CMV so a large um you
know percentage of them will do well and
not have long-term disabilities so I
just wanted to clarify that
so what like why why aren't we talking
about congenital CMV and I'm glad to say
that we are starting to talk about
congenital CMV
um but it has taken a while I think
people talk about it as a silent virus
meaning that they
um
well meaning that it can cause hearing
loss it also is silent in terms of being
you know folks are usually asymptomatic
even babies born with congenital CMV for
the most part you cannot identify them
just you know looking at them or
clinically examining them you have to
test
um and you know also until recently
there wasn't much
um progress in terms of vaccine
development or really antiviral
treatment
um so I think it was something we
weren't talking about because it wasn't
really in our faces and we didn't really
know what we could do about it
um
but that is changing which I'll touch on
in a bit
oh okay let's see I've got some
animations here I'll just explain the
whole thing
so here we've got um a schematic of kind
of the life cycle of congenital CMV or
CMV and how it can become congenital CMV
so I'll start at that um top orange
arrow zero positive mothers so um women
who have had CMV in the past
um or a current infection
um can and often do shed shed the virus
in their breast milk so it depends on
the study but 30 to 70 percent of women
can be shedding CMV in their breast milk
at any time
uh this then can infect the nursing
infant and of those nursing infants
around 50 will be infected
and um you know this is
acquiring CMV through breast milk is
generally not harmful at all um really
the exception is for those you know
super preemie babies or medically
vulnerable infants but then you know the
the child or infant is infected and
grows up and then can pass that
infection through
um saliva tears urine you know through a
reactivation or whatnot to people who
are in close contact with them
um and this can and people that they are
sharing bodily fluids with now
um if any of you have uh have a toddler
at home or have seen a toddler they are
sharing bodily fluids with everyone you
know there's diapers and they're putting
things in their mouths and they're so
um daycares are actually
um a really
um it's a reservoir almost for this
infection meaning that one children have
a CMV infection they continue to shed
the virus for months and months after
any symptoms if they even had any were
um present so you know then it just
passes around the daycare and then these
kids can then bring it back to other
people they have close contact with
which namely in this situation is mom so
um congenital CMV is more common in
second or third babies
um and when folks have looked at the
strain a virus from um infected in the
baby born with congenital CMV it is
often also present in the older sibling
so to reduce CMV risk
um it's really a lot about you know
hygiene as best as you can but like if a
baby acquires it from nursing we don't
want to discourage breastfeeding it's
wonderful
um so this is really why we need a
vaccine individuals who work with
children can take up precautions to
protect themselves from a second
infection or another strain or a primary
infection
um and you know this is things like not
sharing food with young children not
kissing on the lips at least during that
or that pregnancy window or even before
pregnancy
um you know don't share straws like
really double down on the hand washing
um after diaper changes you know it's
interesting there's a study from
Portugal I believe that showed that the
incidence of congenital CMV or sorry
Jose the prevalence went down during the
covid the height of the covid pandemic
in 2020 when all the daycares were
closed and kids were home with their
their families and so there wasn't kind
of that transmission at daycare but
that's the theory at least
um and there have been some really nice
studies recently that have shown that
prenatal counseling about these
behavioral changes
um can actually impact the behavior in
pregnancy and you know the hope is then
it will lower the risk of zero
conversion and then um transmission to
the to the fetus
I should say it won't lower
Transmissions to the fetus but if the
mom doesn't have it circulating in her
um in her system then then that won't
transmit to the fetus I think you get
what I'm saying
so these are just kind of five simple
tips don't share a toothbrush don't do
the thing where when the pacifier falls
on the ground you like clean it by
putting it in your mouth like it sounds
gross but like so many people do it and
then put it in the baby's mouth things
like that
so of women who get CMV circulating you
know an active infection or re-infection
in
in pregnancy about a third is actually
transmitted to the fetus it is also
thought to be the leading cause of um in
viral the leading viral cause of
intrauterine fetal demise and pregnancy
loss this is something that there's
emergency emerging research on
um but it has been really interesting um
to kind of see this new you know area I
think that is really under recognized
and then of course the primary infection
then becomes dormant or latent and then
there are those reactivations which we
touched on
the transmission to the fetus
um is most there's an increased risk of
transmission in primary infections
um yet the majority of infants with CMV
are born to mothers with non-primary
infections meaning either a new strain
or a reactivation and that's just
because so many people have been exposed
to CMV
um so just like sheer numbers
I'm just going to click through all
right here we go
so
of the babies I'm going to start with
this Orange Box of the baby or sorry of
the mothers
who are cmv's positive so zero positive
with a non-primary infection
um around three percent of them will
transmit
um to the fetus and
um a CMV negative over here Mom says
you're a negative with a primary
infection
um really sorry this should just say
primary infection not reinfection a
primary infection around 40 of that will
transmit to the fetus and you know the
sequelae are hearing loss CNS sequelae
and then of course I'm always concerned
for um pregnancy loss and miscarriage
the severity of CMV in terms of its
impact on the fetus it's most severe the
earlier in pregnancy the virus is
transmitted and that just makes sense
because you think of all the downstream
structures
um and you know just like
um
creation of organs and you know brain
development that can happen if one of
those early
um kind of precursors are affected is
affected
um interestingly though transmission is
much more much more likely later in the
pregnancy and so I think that's um you
know likely due to blood flow and
placental blood flow but the impact the
potential impact is not as great
so thinking of mechanisms of fetal
injury there are three main mechanisms
um that you know causes the fetus to be
injured from this virus so placental
injury there can be a lot of like
vasculopathy inflammation in the
placenta which can um result in like end
organ damage
um really like you know insufficient
blood flow
um infants can be born with growth
restriction
there's also viral replication actually
in fetal cells and especially this this
is a neurotropic virus meaning it loves
like fetal uh CNS cells and so it can
disrupt development and
um you know Downstream effects of that
are
can be very significant and then there's
also that maternal immune response you
know some antibodies and inflammation to
kind of to fight
um off the infection is a good thing but
too much is not and so with all that
going on with the immune response we can
have disrupted cell replication and
apoptosis so this is just a broad
overview of what can go wrong but you
know it can be a lot
and the virus
um does thinking about you know how it
affects the fetal brain replicates an
astrocytes neurons microglia there are
more the earlier infections can disrupt
cortical development and also
interestingly CMV can affect host gene
expression so recently um there was a
really cool study and I hope I'm getting
this right that
um found that CMD can actually
um
let's see I guess I think it was turned
off a gene that prevents or decreases
the likelihood of like lists encephaly I
might have that backwards it might turn
on the gene but um it can affect that
Gene host expression and um the
downstream effects of that um you know
you can actually sometimes physically
see in the fetus
and so thinking about all the ways that
this virus can affect a fetal brain the
neurodevelopmental outcomes then follow
so um intellectual disability learning
disabilities hearing loss vestibular
disorders meaning like balance
gaze tracking cerebral palsy motor
planning disorders epilepsy autism as
well and I put a star I'm next to that
because this is an area of developing
research but I think it's fascinating
and I clinically I've seen a lot of
autism in my patients also um you know
visual loss or impairment from the
inflammation in the eye
in general we're seeing about 20 of all
comers with congenital CMV have hearing
loss by 18 years old
um 60 of infants with signs at Birth so
those are the sickest will have
long-term disabilities but again looking
at all comers we're thinking about 75
will have largely typical outcomes based
on what we know right now in the
literature which is actually really
um I I think really encouraging
I want to shift now to talk about the
presentation at Birth
so right now by and large CMV is kind of
categorized by whether or not or the
severity of congenital CMV is
categorized by whether or not an infant
is born with visible signs at Birth so
most infants with congenital CMB are
born asymptomatic I put that in like air
quotes because we'll talk about that in
a little bit about and do they truly
have no symptoms and these babies have
no clinical signs at Birth
um no blood tests that indicate that um
like no
um low platelets or
um you know blood tests that indicate
that there is like some liver
inflammation or hepatitis going on
um but these babies can still have
hearing loss and they can have profound
hearing loss at Birth but as long as the
labs are okay and the head Imaging is
okay and they look okay at Birth they're
still asymptomatic
um 10 are um
symptomatic meaning they have those
visible signs at Birth laboratory
abnormalities or intracranial findings
on Imaging when um head ultrasound is or
MRI is done
so this is kind of a baby sometimes we
talk about the blueberry muffin baby or
blueberry muffin rash and
um this is a little girl she actually
lives in Germany and she's like nine or
ten now and gave me permission to use
this picture
um but this is symptomatic disease and
that's having one or more of these signs
at Birth so small for gestational age
microcephaly small head this particular
rash which you can see on her there's
like pinpoint little like purple dots
jaundice and it's a particular type of
jaundice it's not just like
run-of-the-mill jaundice
um enlarged liver and spleen seizures
there are the other things like
intracranial findings
um so abnormalities and how the brain
formed or some like Hallmarks of CMV
inflammation like calcifications in the
brain
um and um again the laboratory
abnormalities this does not take into
account in account take into account
hearing loss
um and these two ladder findings
um are not visible right you can't see
them unless you know to look for them
so it is so that that baby I should say
um is a baby who is severely affected by
CMV but like I said it is the silent
leading cause viral cause of birth
defects in the U.S because you know here
I want to show you another picture of a
um a severely affected baby
and so this here I can't help but smile
this is my third daughter uh her name's
Odessa and she was born with um
severely symptomatic congenital CMV but
you would never have known it and I
didn't know it nobody knew it just by
looking at her look at that perfect head
she's so sweet
um I had a very seemingly typical
pregnancy with her I delivered
um at term she kind of it was kind of a
message delivery so she did have some
little spots on her forehead but you can
see that with a lot of babies
um she did feel her newborn hearing
screen but I had spent my whole career
reassuring moms that was likely a false
positive because the the false positive
rate for a newborn hearing screen is
roughly 90 percent so you know after her
delivery being a bit rough I was like of
course I'm not worried and I was
determined to go home and not be one of
those worried moms well I mean of course
like you can see where this is going we
um we took her home we you know enjoyed
our like crazy hectic
um first couple months as a family of
five
these children were very young it was
really hectic
um and then when she was around two and
a half months I took her in for her
repeat hearing screen thinking it would
just be whatever like another thing
we're checking off
um but unfortunately
um she was found to have profound
bilateral hearing loss meaning zero
hearing and when she was born one of the
reasons I wasn't worried about her
hearing was that when her sisters would
run around the room and drop things she
would startle but by the time we had her
hearing rechecked you know what hearing
she may have had that birth was gone
um
we were we went to see an
otolaryngologist who is an excellent
clinician and we were told that it was
likely genetic which is true
um that's the most common cause of
hearing loss and I asked about
congenital CMV not not because I had
some like maternal gut feeling or some
like premonition I was just like going
through my lists of things that I could
like sort of remember from my training
um and we were told that it's probably
not CMV because she looks so normal
um but long story short we did find out
it was and then when we did a head
ultrasound through her soft spot there
were multiple
um signs of CMV in her brain
um which is heartbreaking
um but it's extra heartbreaking because
um you know had we known this at Birth
she would have been eligible for
antiviral medication which has been
shown to you know modestly improve
developmental outcomes at 24 months
that's the best study we have right now
um but we kind of missed out on that
window
and who knows who knows the sum of her
hearing would have been preserved
um but also like looking back as a
clinician like I was staring at this kid
24 hours a day and I didn't see it so I
don't think that anybody like missed
something at the hospital this is just
really why we need to screen for this
um in um in newborns
so Odessa she got Cochlear implants and
this is like where I used to stop the
talk and be like and now she's great and
look how sweet she is she's almost four
she's like so much bigger than this now
um but really you know thing this is uh
this is her now things have been really
tough she has had Global developmental
delay she could not hold her head up
until she was six months old and that
was with like twice a week um Physical
Therapy really intensive we did do the
antiviral medication even though we were
late and I don't know if it had any
effect but it does it does have the
effect of suppressing the immune system
and causing neutropenia so she had to be
pulled out of daycare you know now
um she she is on the autism spectrum she
you know is deaf and is communicating
through a mixture of sign and
um You Know spoken language but gosh it
has been really hard it is not just
hearing loss and
um you know I think this is really like
part or this is the reason why I became
interested in CMV and I'm trying to you
know spread the word not the virus right
um to really talk start talking about
this which it's a big public health
problem
so one percent of babies with congenital
CMV are thought to be diagnosed based on
how they look the other 99 if you don't
have a screening program we're not
catching them
and so you know what about these
asymptomatic babies the ones that look
normal or you know don't have any
findings I should say
well the asymptomatic babies can still
have hearing loss as I mentioned
vestibular disorders speech and language
delays which are tied to the hearing
loss
um they're low tone they might walk late
um and then I personally as a
developmental pediatrician really worry
about other conditions that maybe we're
not
um we just don't know about enough about
yet
um
and so you know roughly 20 of these kids
will have hearing loss by 18.
um you know that might be yeah 20 15 to
20
um around half of them will have
vestibular disorders and gaze stability
dysfunctions and there's some debate
about whether or not that might
translate into literacy um difficulties
I I don't know
um but and then 30 of asymptomatic kids
will have balance um difficulties
so I mean really asymptomatic is a
confusing misnomer and we just we just
need to be done with it
um you cannot categorize a complex
disease like this into two buckets you
just can't
um and you know I also worry about as I
said autism or risk learning
disabilities developmental delays that
are subtle in these kids the research
hasn't been super robust
um in this area so um you know this is
something I hope I'm wrong like gosh I I
really hope I'm wrong
um but this is kind of my hunch and
something that I um you know am
currently researching
I'm um just going to summarize this
slide quickly this was a study
um from Europe that looked at 34 infants
with known congenital CMV they were
screened at Birth but a normal physical
exam
when they did Labs head Imaging hearing
and vision screening or testing 56 of
these babies ended up having one or more
findings and this was done in Europe so
their criteria for treatment is
different but
um you know you can at 56 so all of
these babies did end up then meeting
criteria for antiviral treatment
and you know this these are all kind of
the different things that they found 45
of these kids or sorry let me back up 45
of the 56 percent
had abnormal head Imaging which is like
massive right in terms of potential
developmental outcomes and things that
we can do in terms of intervention to
support these kids but if you don't look
you don't know
so clinically
um congenital CMV you know I see a lot
of those kids but autism is my first
love and what I you know has been my
bread and butter of my career
um sorry you can hear my little co-host
um so I love a spectrum and I think this
is where we need to go in terms of uh
congenital CMD babies might be born
symptomatic or asymptomatic but in terms
of where they end up
um in terms of like whether or not they
develop cerebral palsy or cognitive
delays or you know hearing loss I I
think like kids are gonna move kind of
around this spectrum of severity and you
can't just predict that based on how
someone looks at Birth there's so much
right that goes into Child Development
um and so this is kind of where I'm
hoping we are headed
next I'm going to shift here to
diagnosis and detection
so why screen for CMV I mean hopefully
I've started to make that point
um you can't tell by looking at most
babies and babies
to diagnose congenital CMV you have to
test the specimen that has been
collected before 21 days of age after 21
days of age it's been found that you
really cannot tell a congenital
infection from a postnatal infection you
know through breast milk or whatever
which postnatal infection is generally
harmless so before 21 days one can test
urine saliva those are the preferred
samples can also be found in you can
also do a dry blood spot PCR although
the sensitivity is much lower
um but those are the ways that you can
test before 21 days after 21 days you're
really only left with that dried blood
spot PCR because you know that that
specimen was collected before 21 days of
age but a lot of these kids if we're not
screening at Birth they're not
presenting with signs or symptoms until
way after this 21 days of age and so
kids are getting missed and for children
who are asymptomatic or sorry back that
up symptomatic signs at Birth have an
intracranial findings even if it's just
a few calcifications you know they are
thought to be eligible or they are
eligible for antiviral treatment which
ideally has started before 31 days of
age so we're just in this real time
crunch all these kids even if they don't
qualify for antiviral treatment are at
risk of progressive or late onset
hearing loss and there is treatment and
I use that term very broadly not just
medication but there's treatment for all
kids
so what do I mean by that so
the antivirals valgan cyclovira there's
one type that um is given right now for
the most severely affected it is a six
month course like I said before it is no
walk in the park and um you know there
are some studies and rats that show you
know possible
um teratogenicity
um so it's not a decision to be taken
lightly
um but for everybody early intervention
that like developmental monitoring
um you know making sure that if these
kiddos have some
like speech delay that they're getting
those supports right now instead of a
watch and wait you can also manage the
existing sequelae so um you know to know
oh my child has hearing loss we're going
to pursue you know
sign language and or hearing you know
Aid or cochlear implant you know to
manage those sequelae monitor for new
sequelae hearing loss in congenital CMV
it can really progress quickly and it
can be late on set
um so it's important to monitor for that
as well as you know all sorts of those
developmental delays and then family
support I mean I think this is huge and
I think one of the most healing things
for me has been connecting with other
families and just like um you know
people who get it and really being able
to um or to feel understood and
supported and you know to Rally your
network of people that you know can help
you
um so this is why I think everyone can
be treated
but there are certainly barriers right
change is hard
um and so to get the right now to get
the um
specimen for testing or for screening
right now the most the preferred
specimens like I said are saliva which
is a little kind of Q-tip swab Buckle
swab in the cheek
or a urine now
getting a urine on like a one day old is
really hard we would not cath these
babies and so you get this like little
sticky bag it looks like a Ziploc bag
and you stick it on there under the
diaper and you hope that they they pee
which babies don't usually urinate much
in those first few days of life
um then you have to
sorry
goodness then you have to send that to
the lab and did they pee enough and it
can hold up discharge like the urine bag
is really really hard the saliva swab
you know that is another option
um it can be done right now with point
of care testing
um but it's really
um you have to have kind of this one
specific machine for it
um and I think actually like because of
the availability of some saliva swabs in
Industry that has really opened up the
doors for a lot more screening programs
and hospitals which is great
um but it's a whole new system and so
you know it's a barrier right we have to
adjust and then like I mentioned dry
blood spot is um
just not as sensitive depending on the
lab it goes to it could be as low as 60
sensitive
um up to low 80 percent if you send it
to Mark slice's lab in Minnesota there's
a little plug
so what are the different approaches to
testing or screening for congenital CMV
so we can do hearing targeted screening
meaning the babies who fail their
newborn hearing screen or are found to
have hearing loss are then tested for
CMV
um you know this actually only detects
around seven percent of all comers with
congenital CMV and actually it misses 43
of the babies with congenital CMV who
will develop hearing loss by two months
and that's because the hearing loss
associated with congenital CMV
especially earlier on in life it um can
fluctuate which is crazy
um it can
um progress really rapidly it can also
just be like somewhat like slightly
delayed onset but still present by two
months so it's you know we're catching
over half of babies who will have
hearing loss by two months but
not a whole lot of you know only seven
percent of all comers and then there's
routine or Universal screening you just
screen all the babies
um that'll catch them all
um but you know people will argue For
Better or For Worse
so here we go
so you know there are some challenges I
think also opportunities and screening
you know congenital CMV is rarely a
life-threatening condition and most of
the conditions I think currently
screened for on
um on the newborn you know screening
tests are life-threatening
um but neither is hearing loss you know
there are some exceptions there it's an
infectious disease versus a heritable
which is different than the other um
conditions that we screen for but you
know it is actionable
um and you know there are increasing
opportunities for low cost point of care
testing um that you know can run many
specimens and I I think that could
really you know make this um Universal
testing feasible screening I should say
and there are some really exciting pilot
projects going on Minnesota's got some
really cool work going on they're
screening gosh I think it's like 30 000
maybe 25
000
um infants for CMV using uh saliva urine
and dried blood spot
um so that will be really cool to kind
of see what their outcomes are and I
think that will then you know help us
really inform
um these early screening initiatives
um I'm
I'm gonna just Breeze over this so the
recommended uniform screening panel as
part of the foundation we did submit an
application in the fall of 2021
um we just got some um
it's not like reviews or comments back
and some recommended changes that we
hope to address so and you know I think
this review process I think here I put
three to five years that was probably
optimistic but um we're recommending you
know screening with saliva and then um
following that up with a urine PCR for
confirmatory and that's because you know
baby's nurse and there can be
um you know breast milk transferred CMV
um that you know could could create a
false positive for a saliva swab so you
need that confirmatory urine
so hearing targeted screening you know
this is kind of my like big picture
it misses wait I should it misses most
cases yeah that's right it misses most
cases of CMV but catches some but I
think like heck it's better than nothing
um and you know sometimes you just need
to start small and develop that
infrastructure and then build upon that
um you know as is feasible Universal
screening so that would detect all
infants possibly more challenging to
implement I think this is a gold
standard to work towards again this is
my editorializing
um you know I think
um I mean I think this really needs
needs to happen
so in terms of state regulations and
policy
um
sorry it looks like some of my graphic
design here has shifted in my slide
that's fine ignore the um purple
so the state regulations and policy
around congenital CMB are gaining
momentum like super exciting I feel like
over the last year every time I blink I
mean every like couple of months there's
another state that has passed
legislation
um you know really I'd like to see
screening not be
you know
initiated by legislation right I'd love
it to be you know Public Health
researchers and
um you know pediatricians and coming
together and deciding you know this is
the right thing to do
um but right now this is kind of where
we're at so um you can see kind of that
teal turquoise that's where a screening
or education law is enacted
um meaning like maternal education and
so
um there are some laws proposed recently
Minnesota is really exciting so
Minnesota passed the nation's first
Universal screening
um Universal cmv's screening legislation
although
um you know they passed
um the act and then but it wasn't that
which created the program then the
public health commissioner and the um
kind of their newborn screening Review
Committee had to you know review it and
decide whether to recommend it
um but that all passed so you know knock
on wood early uh 2023 Universal
screening for CMV is going to be
happening in Minnesota and I think we're
all watching them you know very closely
and very excited um to see the results
of that
so how do we test for congenital CMV
there are three kind of big options
um maternal testing right if one was
pregnant if you got antibodies before a
woman was pregnant and then tested again
after you know if she hadn't been
exposed to congenital CMV or to CMV you
might see a zero conversion in pregnancy
if she was exposed to CMV that would
just it's not that's not very sensitive
um the windows for serial conversion are
you know quite different and it's really
um doesn't really tell us a lot about
the exposure or whether or not the fetus
will be infected of course feed it for
the fetus can see sometimes things on
ultrasound if there are you know severe
sequelae
um and amniocentesis which in itself is
not without risk uh for newborns PCR has
really become the preferred method so
urine or saliva are the preferred
specimens
um you could do viral culture it's
really not done um too much anymore it's
just not it's not a quick turnaround
it's not good for
um uh screening or you know large-scale
programs but I suppose you could on the
individual patient
so um speaking of testing uh for
screening for congenital CMV so
um
diasaurin has actually come out or is
has developed and it's currently
undergoing FDA approval so are under
review
um but they have a product called it's
the simplexa but it's for congenital CMB
the congenital CMB direct which I'm
really excited about because I think
that this you know might be a game
changer in terms of how we can screen
babies for congenital CMV at Birth
um so just kind of a over arching and um
you know I'm a developmental
pediatrician so
um pardon me you know for my explanation
as I'm kind of going to Breeze through
things
um but what's really cool about this is
that you can use either saliva SWA or
you can use a swab it's like a Q-tip you
know flock swab saliva or urine
um and um it you can do the urine you
know from a bag or a container but it
doesn't have to be much which is really
cool
um the throughput is you know one to
eight samples per run and the run time
is only about 70 minutes the really cool
thing here is the Hands-On time is about
like one minute per run
um and you know I think this
um I you know I think this is going to
be it is compatible with the other um
simplexa
um you know tests that are out there um
other microbial microbiology Labs may
already be using some of these products
so it is my hope that this actually will
be really easy for um some larger
Healthcare institutions to you know
Implement and integrate into their flow
in terms of making testing more feasible
um the intended use for this is
um screening meaning that um you know
you would have to follow up a positive
saliva result with a confirmatory urine
again because of the possible
possibilities in uh false positives
um and you know this is just um this is
a table and now I'm seeing that these um
numbers are pretty small but the
clinical agreement you know in their
studies has um has been you know really
encouraging
um in terms of both saliva and urine um
so I'm I'm really hopeful I've been
saying this you know because of covet
everything got pushed back but I've been
like waiting for this for like gosh uh a
year no probably two years now so I
think they're getting close
I'll just wrap up here by talking about
the or the national CMD Foundation
um so our mission is to prevent
pregnancy loss childhood death and
disability due to congenital CMV we are
a small But Mighty organization we have
two full-time staff and so a lot of what
we're able to do is really driven by our
families and parents and so you can see
these are some of the parents that have
shared their stories with us um
or you know share their stories and
their pictures are on our website and
their stories are on our website and you
know you can really see the degree to
which these babies are obviously
affected or you know not so obviously
affected
um and then you know I think just seeing
the faces of their family really kind of
helps like you know Drive make the
connection in terms of this disease
really impacting lives
check out our website there's lots of
like cool resources on there so I'm I'm
gonna stop and thank you so much for
having me this is a picture of Odessa
now
um she goes to a School for Deaf
children and we went to this um this
like kids museum and like the first
thing she does is gets her lab coat on
gets a play otoscope and is like
checking the ears
all the animals which you know they
check her ears often at school so
um you know I just love to see kids like
playing out real life
um so I'm happy to take questions thank
you
thank you so much Dr press for that
insightful talk we really appreciate
your time it looks like we have a few
questions that have come in during your
presentation so I will go ahead and
start with this first one
any thoughts on the next states that may
vote on our past Universal screening
legislation now that Minnesota has set
the Precedence
yeah I think there's been a lot of
action towards that in Massachusetts
which has been pretty exciting I think a
lot of people are working or watching
Minnesota closely
um to see kind of how that plays out
um you know in Canada there are Ontario
has been doing this since 2019
um so that's Universal screening so
people watch them first and then now in
Canada we're seeing additional provinces
turns so Saskatchewan has been the most
recent one
um so I think you know that's
I I think there are a lot of people or a
lot of states that have already
implemented hearing targeted screening
that you know may then consider
expanding and you know newborn screening
doesn't usually go through or isn't
usually implemented through legislation
right CMV is kind of like a unique
condition in that sense
um and so you know I'm hopeful that we
will see more and more
um State uh Health departments include
CMV and it may not need to go through
legislation
okay great
can you discuss any anticipated
implementation pitfalls or challenges
Labs could expect when considering A
congenital CMV testing program that
includes primary screening followed by
confirmation testing is there a concern
about the ability to obtain the
confirmatory urine specimen would the
clinician
report the first result or wait until
the confirmatory testing result
yeah that's a great question well you
know I think when people talk about
different ways of universal screening or
any sort of newborn screening you know
there's centralized screening where
um you know all the samples are sent to
one lab or so in the state and then you
know there's point of care screening you
know it's then like in a local lab or on
the floor or you know what not and I
think in the case of CMV I mean I can
see arguments in both directions and it
really depends on the specimen type but
if we're talking about saliva
um swabs as kind of the first screen
which is kind is the most common and
really what we're seeing kind of
um in most places then I think you know
that can be done relatively easily with
a very quick turnaround time you know on
the floor
um in the hospital and then you know
after that you would you know pursue the
confirmatory I think there is something
really nice about having a captive
audience to get that confirmatory
testing and so
um you know meaning like we've seen this
with the newborn hearing screen so here
in Michigan we
um you know screen babies in the
hospital and if they refer or fail then
they are supposed to follow up as an
outpatient for a repeat screening or
diagnostic test
but our loss of follow-up rate is 50 and
that's with you know some really amazing
program coordinators trying to track
down these families and texting and
talking to pcps and so forth so I think
it's really going to be critical to
um you know have a tool or um
that can be used
they can have that fast turnaround time
so I guess what I'm saying is I think
saliva can be done relatively quickly
and if there is a positive we do have to
confirm it because false positives can
occur
um with breast milk or you know even
just being born you can pick up CMV
um but then you know the urine
confirmatory if that can be run in-house
too it shouldn't be too too difficult to
get and you know that being said when we
collect urines on babies it's not like a
cath or anything really like invasive
um for babies what you do is you it's
like these little like Ziploc bags with
like sticky on it so you stick it on
under the diaper and um you know you
wait for them to pee and you can run the
same or run the test usually off a
pretty small amount so
um there will be difficulties
um in terms of that year in collection
possibly delaying discharge because
babies really don't urinate too much in
that first couple days of Life they like
hold on to their fluids
um just physiologically so I think that
will be a challenge I think
um you know it's an opportunity to
really
um connect with the primary care
physician and educate the families about
the importance of you know getting that
urine at our Hospital sometimes when we
do a urine collection
um and you know the family's waiting for
the baby to pee the baby isn't peeing
you know sometimes we'll discharge
families home with a little we call it
like a to-go baggie and it's got all the
supplies you need to do a urine
collection at home it's relatively
simple and it doesn't need to be like
super sterile
um and so they can then return that
sample to the lab but anytime you let a
kiddo go you know you do have that risk
of loss of follow-up so I think you know
as with our newborn screening it's
always going to be our newborn hearing
screening it's always going to be
something that you know we're going to
work on and you know work to improve
foreign
we know there is a correlation between
education and the annual incident of
newborns disease and conditions
including congenital CMV is there any
push from the medical community to drive
education and tools to improve women's
knowledge of CMV during prenatal care
while individual State legislation takes
track if not is there any reason why the
lack of obstetrical provider's
involvement
yeah absolutely so I think there has
been a push again it's first kind of
come through legislation which has been
uh is really unique to CMV I think um
you know and not being an obstetrician
myself
um you know I can speak to what I've
kind of heard and seen but of course I'm
not in the trenches taking care of these
patients in the same way
um for the most part I actually think
the um knowledge among obstetric
um providers in the United States about
CMV it's actually pretty low
um and I think that's just because it
hasn't been a condition that's been
really prioritized by the professional
organizations so
um you know a lot of people
um you know CMD moms like myself you
know when you first find out about this
think like why didn't my provider tell
me about it and yes I think that's you
know definitely an okay feeling to have
than
um you know a good question asked but a
lot of the times the providers
themselves aren't really that educated
hated about it so I think you know the
push
um you know has to come from even you
know higher so the professional
organizations
um you know and as well as like Outreach
to to the providers and and women
themselves
um so there are several states that have
some education mandates
um in place so you know there's
materials being distributed Public
Health campaigns
um those unfortunately have not seemed
to really move the needle in terms of
awareness of congenital CMV at least in
Utah and Utah's been doing this for the
you know the longest and um you know the
awareness about CMV among women
um has really stayed around that nine to
ten percent Mark despite you know
Billboards and so forth so you know I
what I think is probably going to happen
is that and it's unfortunate but this is
what I think is going to happen is as we
keep screening more babies
everyone is going to know somebody with
a baby with CMV and to tell you the
truth everybody does know a baby with
CMV right now or a person affected by
CMV it's one in 200 I mean it's so
common we just don't know that we know
them right so as more babies are getting
screened I think we're going to have
more and more you know Healthcare
professionals parents just a general
public asking these questions why aren't
we talking about this why aren't we you
know talking more about risk reduction
or prevention and pregnancy and I think
you know it's kind of this roundabout
way but I I suspect that that's how
we're going to start to really see the
change
um and you know in some ways the change
that we've seen thus far has been really
um spurred forward by Angry Moms kids
doesn't even be you know these parents
that are like how did this happen and
you know my like myself included
um and there's kind of these big systems
issues so I don't want to come across
like I'm pointing the finger one
particular provider or you know it's
pediatricians too but I think um I think
that's really how we're going to see
um you know this move forward and I I
will say that the um ACOG has been
publishing more about CMV and had a
really great panel at their last
conference so
um I I think that the um you know I I
think the tides are turning
okay
well I think we've come to the end of
our time for today I want to thank you
again for this very very interesting
insightful presentation and your time
if you want to get a hold of Dr cash her
contact information is on the thank you
screen that's up right now I also want
to thank all of you that that have
participated and joined us today and I
hope that you continue to enjoy the rest
of the event and enjoy the rest of your
day thank you very much
thanks for having me